I'm Matt Bailey marketing automation
faculty chair
welcome to the foundation series for
email marketing so in this course we're
going to learn how a mail works with
your other channels to bring them up but
also to create a more loyal engaged
customer we're going to talk through the
terminology understand a little more
about what is spam and how you can avoid
getting on spam lists how to grow
maintain your list and how to build the
critical components of an email
marketing campaign and then manage it
and measure it so that you know you are
hitting success now the problem with
email is that it always hasn't been so
sexy in creating value to the company
marketers when they got ahold of email
started asking themselves what's
possible rather than asking should we do
this and as a result when you ask people
what the problem with email is they'll
tell you I get too much it's not
relevant it's not important
it's I'm getting email from people I
don't even know and so because of that
email suffered a reputation problem
there were things that we were receiving
that we didn't know how to control lists
that we got on that we don't know how we
got on those lists and ultimately the
messages were just spammy and not even
targeted and so this created almost a
split personality now that email is the
primary source of spam that I receive
but it's also the primary messaging
medium from a lot of companies that I do
want those messages and so email has had
a bit of a comeback because of the
technology because of mobile marketing
and because of companies using it in a
way that's smarter and more targeted in
creating a conversation with the
customer
one study by the Direct Marketing
Association shows that for every dollar
that was spent in email marketing
companies received 40 dollars in revenue
the power of email marketing is that it
creates loyalty among your customers and
your customers respond to that because
they get to know you it's a way to
educate to expand and to grow customers
into knowing more about your company
which results in a higher lifetime value
than most other marketing channels email
creates value to the company how has
email been transformed from this once
spam filled marketing method to becoming
one of the most powerful marketing
methods now in your marketing arsenal
the first thing is most people start
their day not only with that first cup
of coffee but going through their email
they're looking to see all the messages
that they've received all the marketing
deleting reading keeping up on the news
mostly that's through email but also the
proliferation of mobile devices has now
increased the accessibility to email
people have their email with them all
the time and now one out of every two
email opens is on a mobile device
customers actually prefer to receive
marketing messages via email rather than
any other channel they want to control
that and they have the time to deal with
it when they can and so email is the
preferred method of receiving those
messages and it also contributes to a
higher lifetime value in getting
customers and getting new customers to
your business in this introduction
course I want to challenge you with your
thinking about email
do you really know it a lot of people
assume that they know email and it's
become a very boring subject it's
typically how I get all my spam is from
email how does what a lot of people say
but the problem is you don't know what's
been happening
in the email industry over the past few
years email has become one of the most
powerful ways of reaching new customers
retaining old customers and building a
lifetime customer that will continue to
be a part of your business
you